largely abandoned Villages along
lebanon's 120 km Southern border with
Israel are military
zones the destruction is widespread in
some neighborhoods little is left Israel
is targeting what it says are Hezbollah
cells and infrastructure while the
Lebanese armed group attacks Israeli
troops and positions the conflict
triggered by Israel's war on Gaza has
been largely confined to a strip of
territory a few kilom on both sides of
the Border but the nature of the
conflict is
changing targeted killings of Hezbollah
members or Allied groups appears to be a
new strategy the Israeli strikes more
often than not are kilometers deep
inside Lebanese territory away from the
Battleground front
lines and at times Beyond lebanon's
borders commanders from groups that are
part of Iran's so-called axis of
resistance
have been also killed officials say
Israel is resorting to the killings to
compensate for being unable to achieve a
military Victory against Hamas after
more than 100 days of war in Gaza the
group which has still not used its full
military capabilities and its latest
confrontation with Israel remains
defiant Israel hints about launching a
fullscale war against Lebanon in reality
it's unable to do that it won't be able
to confront what we prepared for our
enemy it has failed in achieving any of
its objective in Gaza their resistance
is Israel is no longer just responding
to Hezbollah attacks such as in the
first few weeks of the Gaza conflict
it's on the offensive it strikes more
aggressive tensions are high Israel has
already carried out a high-profile
assassination in the Lebanese Capital
killing hamas's number two official and
Israeli War planes don't just fly over
border areas they reach Beirut and
further north flying at low altitudes in
a show of force the conflict is being
described as controlled escalation the
United States has engaged in diplomacy
to ensure there's no allout war on the
Lebanon front but reports from Israel
suggest the effort to remove Hezbollah
fighters from the border through
diplomatic means is stalled zanah huder
Al jaaz
Beirut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz